over the past two months russia has
amassed more than 100 000 troops on the
ukrainian border and everyone is waiting
to see if president vladimir putin will
attempt an invasion but there's another
reason to pay close attention to this
area it's one of the most important
wheat-producing regions on the planet
and no matter where you are in the world
wheat is everywhere including in the
things we buy every single week so what
could an escalation in ukraine mean for
the global grain market and all of us
consumers let's go find out
okay let's go back to that green map for
a second
look at these shaded regions that show
the wheat producing land in russia and
ukraine the greener the shade the more
wheat that's produced as you can see
this area is extremely productive
i mean there's a reason why soviet
symbols and flags and art featured
images of wheat
the land's mineral-rich black soil and
mild conditions make it perfect for
growing grains although the soviet union
system of collective farming was
inefficient and led to shortfalls things
have changed a lot in recent decades
with a shift toward more market-driven
economies russia and ukraine have
unleashed their agricultural power
together the two countries account for
about one-third of global wheat exports
and top importers include egypt turkey
indonesia and pakistan according to the
u.s department of agriculture ukraine is
also a top exporter of other important
staples like corn and barley and most of
those products travel to other countries
by ship via the black sea so now that
you know just how much wheat these
countries grow let's talk about food
prices even just the threat of conflict
has driven wheat prices higher and
traders are watching the region closely
so is wsj commodities reporter will
horner if wheat prices rise by what some
analysts are suggesting then yeah that
means wheat prices everywhere going up
it potentially means food prices
everywhere rising at this point no one
knows how things will play out but
because ukraine's most productive wheat
regions are close to russia and areas
controlled by russian-led separatists
analysts are pricing out a few different
possibilities if russia launches an
all-out invasion of ukraine a worst case
scenario that russia has denied planning
for some say prices could easily double
that's because ukraine's production
could be disrupted and at the same time
russian exports could be sanctioned but
some analysts say even a smaller scale
incursion could push prices 10 to 25
percent higher anything that affects
ukraine's agricultural infrastructure
and that certainly includes ports
is likely to have a big you know impact
on prices ukraine already lost territory
and ports back when russia annexed
crimea in 2014 and many fear that
president putin could attempt a similar
invasion for example russia could make a
play for this territory which putin has
referred to by its tsarist-era term
novorossia or new russia some of it is
already controlled by russian-led
separatists and if russia sought to
expand here it would choke ukraine's
economy by cutting it off from those key
black sea trade routes obviously there
is a lot at stake here for ukraine but
what could a conflict mean for the rest
of the world in terms of wheat global
food prices have already surged and
they're adding to the economic hardship
that many people face due to the
pandemic especially in developing
countries andre seizov a black sea
grains analyst said a further spike in
prices could make matters much worse for
everyone it obviously will be negative
for for the whole world
prices will go everywhere and for all
consumers but obviously the poorer the
countries the bigger will be
the heat to the country and higher food
prices could even lead to unrest in some
parts of the world for example in 2011
we saw that arab spring after in 2010
russia banned its wheat exports if we
see a serious disruption this season and
prices will go up by 20 30 or even
higher these countries mean the
countries that will be a very big
problem for them food prices aren't the
only thing at stake if a conflict breaks
out in ukraine we could see huge global
disruptions when it comes to energy and
metals and even cyber security my
colleagues at the wall street journal
are covering all the developments over
in ukraine so check out wsj.com for the
latest and if you learned something from
this video be sure to subscribe to the
channel for more stories like this one
i'll see you next time